نعم صحيح كنت المراه الوحيده الحاضره بين
كل اعضاء ادارته انا احترم الرجال واحب
العمل معهم واحترم ذكائهم ولكنني اعرف
اشياء كثيره لا يعرفها الرجال ولذلك فمن
الافضل ان نتعاون في العمل على اي حال وفي
شكل مفاجئ جدا اتصل بي بعد وطلب مني زياره
المكتب البيضاوي سبق ان كنت في البيت
الابيض الا انني اندهشت حقا فقط توقعت
انني سادخل لارى الرئيس وسيقول لي مرحبا
بك السيده ماسي حظا سعيدا السيده ماسي
ويلتقط معي الصور ثم يقول لي وداعا السيده
ماسي ولكن ليس هذا ما حدث كان هناك عدد
كبير من الرجال الاداره الامريكيه بالكامل
كانت حاضره عند دخول كلهم كانوا حاضرين
بوش الاب وجيمس بايكر وقد تفاجات لانني لم
اكن اتوقع مواجهه الاداره باكملها اول شخص
شاهدته كان رجلا طويلا جدا وهو ريجان وكما
قلت لك توقعت ان يكون لي مرحبا شكرا سعدت
للقائك وداعا لكن ليس هذا ما حدث حيث قال
لي اجلسي السيده معسي وانا اجلس في احد
المقاعد التي جلس عليها الملوك من قبل كان
علي اتخاذ القرار بحضور كل اعضاء الاداره
الامريكيه مثل بوش وبيكر وانا لم اكن اعرف
حتى سبب وجودهم معنا وعندما طلب مني
الرئيس الجلوس جلست ولم اكن اعرف ما يجب
ان اقول لكنني قمت بعمل ذكي فقررت عدم
الالتفات للنظر الى الحاضرين ثم الالتفات
للنظر الى الرئيس لان ذلك سيبدو غريبا
لذلك تظاهرت بانني اجلس وحدي مع الرئيس
وحققت في عينيه
بالتحدث وفي ذلك اليوم كانت قريحته مفتوحه
للتحدث عن عدم حبه للشيوعيين واستطرد
بالحديث وقد تفاجات جدا لانني كنت جالسه
بالقرب منه بين كل هؤلاء الرجال وكانت تلك
التجربه رائعه ولا اعرف سبب استقباله
باستثناء طلب وهو كان يثق كثيرا بمكفارلا
ولكن دعينا نركز على ما دار بينكما في هذا
اللقاء اكثر يعني قال لك انه لا يحب
الشيوعيين معروف ولكن ماذا قال اكثر عن
هذا الموضوع وكيف رددت عليه
نمبر وان اول مساله مهمه يجب ان ننتبه
اليها هي انه علينا الاصغاء وعندما
يخاطبنا الرئيس وقد اصغيت اليه حدثني ريجن
عن ايام عمله في هوليود عندما كان للشي
حضور قوي جدا وقال لي هل تعرفين ان
شيوعيين في كاليفورنيا كان يطلبون من
الاشخاص هجره عائلاتهم والانضمام الى
الحزب الشيوعي كان هذا في هاليود ولم
يعجبه ذلك وقال لم يعجبه كيف كان يشجعون
الاطفال على ترك عائلاتهم وكان قلقا جدا
من ذلك لا اعرف لماذا رغب في التحدث الي
في ذلك اليوم الا انه استطرد في الحديث عن
شعوره حياله هؤلاء الشيوعيين في هاليود
وباختصار لم يكن موافقا على اساليبهم
اصغيت اليه بكل عنايه وحققت في عينيها
عندما كنت اصغي الى كلامه لم اقاطعه ولم
افعل شيئا سوى الاصغاء وقد تفاجات جدا
وشعرت بالاطراء الشديد لرغبته في التحدث
اليه كل ذلك الوقت ولم اعرف السبب وراء
ذلك لانني لا اعرف ما دار بينه وبين
ادارته قبل لقائنا وسبب حضورهم جميعا هذا
اللقاء وبقائهم طوال الوقت واخيرا وبعد
حديثه الطويل ولطيف اضطروا لاخراجه عنوه
من المكان وعندما خرجت برفقه
سالته كيف تصرفت فقال لي لقد ابليتي بلاء
حسنا ثم قال لي ساحاول ترتيب لقاء اخر